THANK YOU.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
CDC IS WARNING ABOUT A POSSIBLE
FOURTH WAVE OF CORONAVIRUS AS
CASES RISE IN PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
THIS AS VACCINATIONS ALSO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
1 IN 4 ADULTS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE FULLY VACCINATED AND
MORE THAN 112 MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE SHOT.
JOINING US NOW FORMER
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE TESTING
CZAR ADMIRAL GIRARD.
I WILL ASK YOU A YEAR -- THINK
BACK TO A YEAR AGO WHEN YOU
WERE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
DID YOU EVER THINK WE WOULD BE
AT THIS STAGE WHERE WE HAD THIS
MANY VACCINATIONS AND SHOTS IN
ARMS?
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
OF COURSE WE KNEW THAT VACCINES
WERE THE ONLY WAY OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC BARRING EVERYONE
GETTING THE DISEASE.
WE STARTED WORKING ON THAT
IMMEDIATELY.
BUT I COULD HONESTLY SAY THAT
NOBODY WOULD HAVE EXPECTED TO
HAVE THREE AUTHORIZED VACCINES
THAT WERE 100% PROTECTIVE AT
THE DOSES.
SO WE REALLY DO HAVE THE END IN
SIGHT.
IT IS A MIRACULOUS TYPE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND WE COULDN’T
HAVE IMAGINED THIS TYPE OF
SUCCESS.
>> Dana: THESE ARE THE
HEADLINES.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
HOW WORRIED SHOULD WE BE?
"L. A. TIMES," "WASHINGTON
POST", NEW JERSEY.COM AND WINK
SAYING THERE IS A DOUBLE MUTANT
CORONAVIRUS VARIANT THAT IS
SWEEPING THE NATION.
WHAT SHALL WE KNOW ABOUT THIS?
>> MUTATIONS OCCUR ALL THE TIME.
THIS PARTICULAR VARIANT HAS A
COUPLE OF MUTATIONS THAT WE
NEED TO WATCH BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT ALL THESE
VARIANTS, WHETHER IT’S SOUTH
AFRICAN, BRAZIL, U.K. OR THIS
LIKELY DOUBLE VARIANT WILL ALL
BE PROTECTED AGAINST BY THE
VACCINES.
THE VACCINES WORK.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE BOTH OF THEM.
IF YOU HAVE PFIZER OR  MODERNA.
WE NEED TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THESE MUTANTS AND FOLLOW THEM
BUT DOUBLE MUTANT SOUNDS REALLY
AWFUL AND SCARY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
BE SCARED.
THEY SHOULD GET THEIR VACCINES
AND THE END OF THIS WILL BECOME
SOON AFTER THE VACCINES ARE
MORE WIDESPREAD.
>> Dana: 80% OF TEACHERS HAVE
GOTTEN THE FIRST SHOT OF
VACCINES.
YOU’VE BEEN ON HERE BEFORE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT CAN HAPPEN
OR WHAT PEOPLE CAN DO ONCE THEY
GET A VACCINE.
IN YOUR OPINION CAN KIDS AND
TEACHERS GET BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM?
>> TEACHERS AND CHILDREN SHOULD
BE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM
ALREADY.
EVEN CDC SAID IT IS NOT
NECESSARY FOR TEACHERS TO GET
THE VACCINE.
IN TEXAS WHERE I AM CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN BACK IN SCHOOL SINCE
LAST AUGUST.
MY YOUNGER DAUGHTER IS IN
EDUCATION AND IT IS GOING VERY
WELL.
THIS IS CREATING -- IT IS
CAUSING HARM.
THIS IS CAUSING A LOT OF HARM
TO CHILDREN.
VACCINES IS AN ADDED BONUS FOR
THE TEACHERS.
I AM SO HAPPY THEY’RE GETTING
IT.
TEACHERS SHOULD BE BACK IN
SCHOOL WITH THEIR STUDENTS
TODAY AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN SIX
MONTHS AGO.
>> Dana: I WANT YOU TO LISTEN
TO SOUND FROM THE CDC DIRECTOR.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS REAL
QUICK.
>> I’LL REFLECT ON THE
RECURRING FEELING I HAVE OF
IMPENDING DOOM.
RIGHT NOW I’M SCARED.
OUR DATA TODAY SUGGESTS THAT
VACCINATED PEOPLE DO NOT CARRY
THE VIRUS, DON’T GET SICK, AND
THAT IT’S NOT JUST IN THE
CLINICAL TRIALS BUT ALSO IN
REAL WORLD DATA.
I WOULD ADVOCATE AGAINST
GENERAL TRAVEL OVERALL.
OUR GUIDANCE IS BOUND ON
RECOMMENDING OR NOT
RECOMMENDING FULLY VACCINATED
PEOPLE TRAVEL.
>> Dana: THE LAST QUESTION TO
YOU SIR.
HOW ARE AMERICANS SUPPOSED THE
TAKE THE INFORMATION WHAT THEY
ARE SEEING IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES, GETTING THE
VACCINE BUT HEARING MESSAGES
LIKE THAT FROM THE CDC?
FEELS LIKE IT IS CONFUSING.
>> Bill:
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF MIXED
MESSAGES HERE.
THE FACTS WHERE THEY ARE.
IF YOU ARE FULLY VACCINATED YOU
ARE 95% PROTECTED AGAINST
GETTING ANY INFECTION.
IT IS VERY UNLIKELY YOU’LL
TRANSMIT IT.
THERE IS A SMALL CHANCE.
I FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE
TRAVELING.
I’M READY TO GO ON CRUISES
AGAIN WITH A FULLY VACCINATED
CREW AND PASSENGERS.
SO WE’RE NOT OUT OF THIS YET.
I DON’T THINK WE’LL HAVE A
FOURTH WAVE BECAUSE OF THE
VACCINES AND PRE-EXISTING
IMMUNITY FROM PEOPLE GETTING
INFEBTED.
I STILL WEAR A MASK IN PUBLIC.
THERE IS A SMALL CHANCE THAT
EVEN VACCINATED YOU COULD HAVE
A VIRUS AND PASS IT TO SOMEONE
VULNERABLE BUT WE’RE ON OUR WAY
OUT OF THIS.
I DO BELIEVE HERD IMMUNITY IS
AROUND THE CORNER AND DEATHS
CONTINUE TO DECREASE BECAUSE
WE’VE DONE WELL WITH OUR
ELDERLY AND VULNERABLE.
DON’T BE SCARED, BE VIGILANT.
GET YOUR VACCINE AND WE’LL BE